foreign
[Music]
I know your tricks Mariachi what did he
say to you he was just showing me his
guitar shame on you here at Rotten
Tomatoes we want to celebrate Hispanic
culture and Heritage in cinema and what
better way to celebrate than with
favorites for the whole family viewers
of all ages can enjoy these movies that
entertain Dazzle and embrace culture
featuring stars like Rita Moreno Antonio
Banderas Eugenio Derbez and more I'm
sure mama would want you to have it
right Papa
thank you my dear in return you have my
blessing may your heart be always pure
encourages what do we say Manolo thank
you Senora you'll find plenty of
animated Classics like Coco The Book of
Life and the Miles Morales starring
Spider-Man into the spider-verse and if
the power of music is more of your fix
you can sing along to movies like in the
Heights West Side Story and La Bamba and
action abounds in the Zorro and Spy Kids
movies so call Abuelita over and get the
kids off their phones because it is time
for family movie night while we count
down our list of the best Hispanic
movies for the whole family
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
The Book of Life
in the Mexican Town of San Angelo Manolo
Maria and Joaquin have been friends ever
since childhood although their lives
have taken different paths Maria was
sent to Europe Joaquin joined the
military and Manolo study to become a
bull fighter One Thing Remains the Same
though Manolo and wakid both want to
marry Maria little does a trio know that
battling husband and wife deities have
made a high-stakes wager on the love
triangles outcome starring Diego Luna
Zoe Saldana Channing Tatum and directed
by Jorge R Gutierrez critics say the
book of life's gorgeous animation is a
tree but it's a Pity that its story
lacks the same level of craft and detail
that its thrilling visuals provide
you see as long as someone alive
remembers you you get to live in the
land of the remember
what is it it's a cow is on the March
Tim comes the end of your town and there
will be no one left to remember you we
would all be for
we forgot please camel maker
help me go back can't do that Manolo
huh Santa Chihuahua okay okay look guys
The Book of Life it holds everyone's
story but the pages on manolo's life
the blank huh you didn't live the life
that was written for you you are writing
your own stories
number nine The Mask of Zorro
after being in prison for 20 years Zorro
Don Diego De la Vega receives word that
is old enemy Don Rafael Montero has
returned Don Diego escapes and returns
to his old headquarters where he trains
aimless drunk Alejandro morrieta to be
his successor meanwhile Montero who is
secretly raised Diego's daughter Elena
as his own hatches a plot to Rob
California of its gold starring Antonio
Banderas Anthony Hopkins Catherine Zeta
Jones and directed by Martin Campbell
critics say Banderas returns as an aging
Zorro in this surprisingly Nimble
entertaining swashbuckler
oh
come on now
[Music]
I don't have the time to give you the
proper instruction
I have had the proper instructions since
I was four
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
number eight real women have curves
curves on a blossoming young woman can
be sexy but not if you were told that
you have too many of them real women
have curves is a humorous and
warm-hearted look at a Mexican-American
teenage girl coming of age in a boiling
cauldron of cultural expectations class
constructions family Duty and her
personal aspirations starring America
Ferreira Lupe ontiveros Ingrid ol you
and directed by Patricia cardoso critics
say real women have curves physical as
well as emotional this coming-of-age
story traces them in a vividly
warm-hearted look at the
Mexican-American experience please don't
waste the distilled water it's expensive
it's so hot in here seriously I feel
like I'm in hell
foreign
[Music]
only 18.
such a relief we're almost done with
this Anna what are you doing
hi Mama come on it's so hot all the
steam has been sweating like a pig but
we're sweating too but we're not taking
our clothes off why not we're all women
mom we all have the same things
please aren't you hot in those clothes I
feel so sticky aren't you embarrassed of
what look at you you look awful mama I
happen to like myself right on sister he
do
that two of you should lose weight
you would look beautiful without all
that fat
and still are beautiful they look good
the way they are thank you Pancha thank
you Pancha number seven Dora and the
lost city of gold having spent most of
her life exploring the jungle nothing
could prepare Dora for her most
dangerous Adventure yet High School
accompanied by a ragtag group of teens
and Boots the monkey Dora embarks on a
quest to save her parents while trying
to solve these seemingly impossible
mystery behind a lost Incan civilization
starring Isabella Merced uhenio Derbez
Michael Pena and directed by James boban
critics say led by a winning performance
from Isabella Merced Dora in the lost
city of gold is a family-friendly
Adventure that retains its source
materials youthful Spirit hi
being chased by a herd of angry pygmy
elephants hey you say angry pick me up
better luck next time angry elephants
[Music]
pardon me black guy month largest
predator in the Amazon
[Music]
and that's boots hi boots hi Dora what's
today's adventure today we continue our
decades-long search
golden poison frog skin is lethally
toxic and can cause full body paralysis
can you say severe neurotoxicity
number six Puss in Boots
long time before meeting Shrek Puss in
Boots just named a hero for saving a
woman from a charging bowl is run out of
town on suspicion of bank robbery even
though the real villain is puss's friend
Humpty Dumpty though there is still
animosity between them puss and Humpty
reunite to steal a goose that lays
golden eggs joining them for the
adventure of nine lifetimes is notorious
cat burglar Kitty Soft Paws starring
Antonio Banderas Salma Hayek Zach
Galifianakis and directed by Chris
Miller critics say it isn't deep or
groundbreaking but what it lacks in
profundity Puss in Boots more than makes
up for with an abundance of wit visual
Sparkle and effervescent charm
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
no fish sticks for you
number five Spy Kids
two young kids become spies and attempt
to save their parents who are ex-bies
from an evil mastermind armed with a bag
of high-tech gadgets and Out of This
World Transportation Carmen and Juni
will bravely jet through the air dive
under the Seas and crisscross the globe
in a series of thrilling Adventures on a
mission to save their parents and maybe
even the world starring Antonio Banderas
Carlo Gugino Alexa Penavega Daryl Sabara
and directed by Robert Rodriguez critics
say a kinetic and fun movie that's sure
to Thrill children of all ages
that's a safe house looks more like an
outhouse
her name
Carmen Cortez your full name please I
don't use my full name it's too long
your full name please godman and
Elizabeth
my name's a passcode
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
number four West Side Story
a musical in which a modern day Romeo
and Juliet are involved in New York
street gangs on the harsh streets of the
Upper West Side two gangs battle for
control of the turf the situation
becomes complicated when a gang member
falls in love with a rival sister
starring Natalie Wood Richard beimer
Rita Moreno and directed by Jerome
Robbins and Robert Wise critics say
buoyed by Robert wise's dazzling
Direction Leonard Bernstein score and
Stephen sondheim's lyrics West Side
Story remains perhaps the most iconic of
all the Shakespeare adaptations to visit
the big screen
okay now let's now we fought hot for
this Turf and we ain't just gonna give
it up the emeralds claimed it we shot
him out the Hawks remember they tried to
take it away we knock them down the
cellar yeah but these PRS are difficult
to play they keep coming like
cockroaches
and you heard about that Lieutenant
strength said huh we gotta make nice
with them Puerto Ricans or else
we gotta let it move in right under our
noses and take it all away from us or
else damn right now
so what are we gonna do huh buddy boys
I'll tell you what we're gonna do we're
gonna speed fast we're gonna move like
lightning and we're gonna clean them
sharks up once and for all so they ain't
never gonna set foot on our turf again
I'm gonna do it
and one all-out fight a rumble a cool
action boy
sharks want a piece of this world too
and they're real dumb boys
they might ask for uh blades zip guns
zip guns
oh gee playing finalizing and saying I
will baby John I'm just saying that they
might
and we gotta be prepared
now what's your move Jets
number three in the Heights
the creator of Hamilton and the director
of crazy Rich Asians invite you to the
event of the Summer where the streets
are made of music and little dreams
become big in the Heights lights up on
Washington Heights the scent of a
cafecito Caliente hangs in the air just
outside of the 181st Street subway stop
where a kaleidoscope of Dreams rallies
is vibrant and tight-knit community at
the intersection of it all is the
likable magnetic Bodega owner usnavi who
saves every penny from his Daily Grind
as he hopes imagines and sings about a
better life in the Heights fuses
lin-manuel Miranda's kinetic music and
lyrics with director John M Chu's Lively
and authentic eye for storytelling to
capture a world very much of its place
but Universal in its experience starring
Anthony Ramos Melissa Barrera Leslie
Grace and directed by John M Chu critics
say lights up for in the Heights a
joyous celebration of Heritage and
Community fueled by dazzling Direction
and sing-along songs oh man yo bad
change is happening on the Block since
you've been at school
I mean at least your dad can have the
storefront
no the cleanest next door nine dollars a
shirt what yo
Look Who's home
look at
that why are you talking
no my man grew a couple inches he think
he a man man shut up
listen
you down to March next week
like we used to
cause they're talking about kicking out
all the dreamers
it's time to make some noise
you wanna come I
[Music]
tell me
are you good you're done yeah my man
who's watching the store
[Music]
that's on your tab bro both me up
number two Spider-Man into the
spider-verse bitten by a radioactive
spider in the subway Brooklyn teenager
Miles Morales suddenly develops
mysterious powers that transform him
into the one and only Spider-Man when he
meets Peter Parker he soon realizes that
there are many others who share his
special high-flying talents miles now
use his Newfound skills to battle the
evil Kingpin a hulking madman who can
open portals to other universes and pull
different versions of Spider-Man into
our world starring shamik Moore Jake
Johnson Haley Seinfeld and directed by
Bob Percy Shetty Peter Ramsey and Rodney
Rothman critics say Spider-Man into the
spider-verse matches bold storytelling
with striking animation for a purely
enjoyable adventure with heart humor and
plenty of superhero action
you're not going anywhere
I'll hold them off you shut this down
Peter that's what did they do push the
green button
for me
what are you doing Peter you gotta go
home this guy can kill you I can't let
Spider-Man die neither can I
it's okay
yeah it is okay
you gotta go home man
[Music]
how do I know I'm not going to mess it
up again
you won't
right
hey totally perfect
[Music]
not bad kid
and before we reveal number one here are
some honorable mentions
La Bamba
[Music]
La teenager Richie Valens becomes an
overnight rock and roll success in 1958
thanks to a love ballad called Donna
that he wrote for his girlfriend whose
parents didn't want her to date a Latino
boy but as his star Rises Valance has
conflicts with his jealous brother Bob
and becomes haunted by a recurring
nightmare of a plane crash just as he
begins his first national tour alongside
Buddy Holly starring Lou Diamond
Phillips ESI Morales Rosanna DeSoto and
directed by Luis Valdez critics say
elevated by a perceptive performance by
a perfectly cast Lou Diamond Phillips La
Bamba distills its subject's Creative
Energy and reflects his music's enduring
appeal Mexico
you went to Tijuana without telling
anybody
a fine pair of scene that awakes us
I could expect this from Bob but not you
Richie
so what did you do
drink the night away okay it was my
fault I took him there how's Rosie she's
in the hospital where else
she was all alone in here I had a driver
to the hospital myself she was in labor
all day with a baby do you hear me do
you care about anything
go ahead go play with your bike
he had a girl
we named her Brenda
wow
instant family
when Pete and Ellie decide to start a
family they stumble into the world of
foster care adoption they hope to take
in one small child but when they meet
three siblings including a rebellious 15
year old girl they find themselves
speeding from zero to three kids
overnight now Pete and Ellie must try to
learn the ropes of instant Parenthood in
the hope of becoming a family starring
Mark Wahlberg Rose Byrne Octavia Spencer
and directed by Sean Anders critics say
instant family may not quite capture the
complexity of real life adoption but
fittingly for the unconditional Bond it
honors this flawed yet well-intentioned
dramedy is ultimately worth the
investment where's my potato chips oh
we're not having chips tonight munchkin
sorry I want my chips Lita Lizzy Pete
and I worked really hard on this dinner
and there's lots of yummy food for you
to eat
Lizzy no okay I've got this why are you
yelling at me I'm just trying to help
you I'm not yelling I'm sorry I am just
then I was but it's look Nina don't do
what Lizzy just said what would you say
cuatro go to your bedroom
like quart of milk right she said you
you're not gonna have potato chip but
you will drink that milk in any case we
have this it's fine okay fine okay let's
try some of this meatloaf okay
not having chips yeah I don't think
she's getting on board with the plan
honey
you sure you don't want to just give her
some chips no
[Music]
no
I'm sorry I'm so sorry no no it's okay
don't cry relax your feet okay
you give those to me
just stay there
these are really really good potatoes
McFarland USA
track coach Jim White is a newcomer to a
predominantly Latino High School in
California's Central Valley coach white
and his new students find that they have
much to learn about one another but
things begin to change when white
realizes the boy's exceptional running
ability more than just physical prowess
drives the teens to succeed their strong
family ties incredible work ethic and
commitment to their team all play a
factor in forging these novice Runners
into Champions starring Kevin Costner
Maria Bello Morgan Saylor and directed
by Nikki Caro critics say Disney's
inspirational sports drama formula might
be old hat but McFarland USA proves it
still works especially with a talented
director and eminently likable star in
the mix every team that's here deserves
to be
including you
but they haven't got what you got all
right
they don't get up at dawn like you and
go to work in the fields right
they don't go to school all day
and then go back to those same Fields
that's what you do
and then you come out with me and you
run eight miles
10 miles and you take on
you take on even more pain these kids
don't do what you do they can't even
imagine it
I went out in the field that day with
you Dia's kids I'll be honest with you
it was a
some first taste work I ever had to do
in my life
and I said to myself whatever kind of
crappy job I end up in it'll never be as
tough as that
you kids do it every day
and your parents hope they can do it
every day and they'll do it for a
lifetime if it means a better life for
you
you guys are superhuman
what'd you endure just to be here to get
a shot at this the kind of privilege
that someone like me takes for granted
there's nothing you can't do with that
kind of strength
let's have the biggest hearts I've ever
seen
and go run your race
and finally number one Coco
despite his family's generation's old
ban on music Young Miguel dreams of
becoming an accomplished musician like
his Idol Ernesto De La Cruz desperate to
prove his talent Miguel finds himself in
these stunning and colorful Land of the
Dead after meeting a Charming trickster
named Hector the two new friends embark
on an extraordinary journey to unlock
the real story behind Miguel's family
history starring Anthony Gonzalez Gael
Garcia Bernal Benjamin Bratt and
directed by Lee ankrich critics say
Coco's Rich visual Pleasures are matched
by a thoughtful narrative that takes a
family-friendly and deeply affecting
approach to questions of culture family
life and death
[Music]
where
[Music]
is
this isn't a dream then
you're all really out there you thought
we weren't oh I don't know I thought it
might have been one of those made up
things that adults tell kids like
vitamins Miguel vitamins are a real
thing well Amigos that about does it for
us be sure to stay tuned to the Rotten
Tomatoes channel for more of the
entertainment content you love until
next time I am your host Naz Perez and
we'll see you back here for more top
tens on the Rotten Tomatoes countdown
foreign
[Music]